tonight on the new reality
hi grandma you thought you were gonna
die yeah i thought i was gonna die
caregivers struggling to contain the
spread we was getting
mixed messages devastated families on
the outside looking in i knew mom not
seeing me she'd be worried
while the virus ran wild it just seemed
that nobody knew what they were doing
how was kova 19 able to spread so
viciously
in this long-term care home are care
homes better prepared for this second
wave
what really is concerning is that it's
almost like they didn't actually
really learn the lessons that the rest
of us learned the hard way
hello i'm donna friesen canadians have
been living with covid19
and dying from it for more than nine
months now and yet lessons learned in
the first wave
are not being evenly applied in this
second wave
especially in some long-term care homes
about 80 percent of the deaths from
covid19 in canada have been residents in
long-term care
despite all the rhetoric from political
leaders including from ontario's premier
about protecting the most vulnerable in
november of 2020 there are around 160
outbreaks in ontario long-term care
homes
retirement homes and nursing homes our
care homes and their residents and staff
continue to be this pandemic's greatest
victims
why haven't lessons been learned tonight
farah nasser has an exclusive look
at what went on inside one ontario care
home this spring what staff
residents and families were being told
and what they weren't
this is mark haven home for seniors a
non-profit
government-funded long-term care
facility in the toronto suburb of
markham
17 residents died of covid 19 here
during the first wave
and dozens more were infected
it's a scene that played out at hundreds
of seniors homes across canada
caregivers struggling to contain the
spread devastated families on the
outside looking
in while the virus ran wild killing
thousands of residents markhaven looks
calm now
this lonely sign of condolence flapping
in the breeze
the only visual reminder of the tragedy
that played out this spring
but to those who worked in the industry
the warning signs were there
in this field you're always short you
know it could have to do with more staff
especially in the cuvee time not
we work with what we had maggie kittens
worked as a psw at mark haven for
30 years until she got the virus in late
march
she was hospitalized for more than a
month and nearly died
she wasn't the same when she came from
the hospital she was having
like terrifying nightmares she can't
sleep
i can't sleep without sleeping pills
it's hard because i'm a person that
always
on the go always doing something and now
i have to sit down home and depend on my
my kids to do mostly everything for me
because
i had to learn to walk i had to learn to
swallow
i
it's
it's very hard so how was covet covid19
able to spread so viciously in this
long-term care home
we have some answers from internal
documents obtained exclusively by global
muse
they reveal new details about what was
unfolding behind the scenes at mark
haven
between management and regional public
health authorities
it started on march 12th when a resident
came down with a cough and fever
but it was a full five days later before
a markhaven nurse
identified only as yan finally called
and reported it to york region public
health
by that time five more residents were
showing symptoms
on march 20th a 74 year old resident
tested positive
and health officials declared a covid19
outbreak
did you give care to that first patient
it was my assignment i thought my
goodness
we should be wearing everything
and she should be maybe in in hospital
maggie was dealing with an infected
resident while caring for other patients
at the same time
and she was concerned she wasn't wearing
the right gear
i had on this stuff but you're wearing
this
this was it this kind of a mask or was
it an n95 it was this kind of a mask
this yes it wasn't a medical grade mask
this
this as a result of that
i almost lost my life that night
mark haven executive director mike
bakewell sent an email to the family
members of residence
reassuring them mark haven was working
closely with health authorities
and following correct protocols to
contain the spread
but the following afternoon bakewell
sent a long
scathing email to health officials
explaining they were dealing with
a chaotic and stressful situation their
supply of personal protective equipment
was dwindling
and he was dealing with staff abandoning
their posts
he complained of conflicting information
coming from the government
about where to get ppe and what kind of
mask to use
claiming he was fighting tooth and nail
to keep staff in the building
and public health he said wasn't being
helpful
the chaos and confusion behind the
scenes was playing out on the front
lines and staff were getting very
worried we was getting
mixed messages if i could put it that
way
one minute you're told you're not
supposed to do this one minute you're
told you
do this you know so you don't know
which way you're going we were asking
you know
do you guys have masks are you guys
wearing your mask and at that point my
mom said no so we're like you know you
have to demand it
and you have to demand the proper ppe
you guys have to get the n95 mask
but they never got it it was like
in panic inside but you can't show your
panicking
and as i said you know you're trying to
be
as comfortable try to do your work the
best way you can
if workers were getting anxious so were
the families
for chloe eftivolos it was a slow burn
her mother lulu travolus had been at
mark haven for years
she'd gone through the occasional
lockdown for outbreaks of flu but
it wasn't long before chloe realized
this was different
so the first instinct was okay i'll wait
i'll wait a week
and then it was two weeks and then i was
really anxious because i knew mom not
seeing me she'd be worried
chloe said she'd noticed staffing
shortages in the past but her mother was
blind deaf and had dementia
with the home locked down she had no
idea how bad things were getting
staff didn't feel safe working at
markhaven uh because they didn't have a
proper equipment they didn't have enough
workers did you know any of that
no no i'm surprised to hear that
yeah i thought they were well equipped
by march 22nd health officials had told
mark haven to stop staff from working at
multiple homes to contain the spread
but in an email to public health
executive director mike bakewell said
nearby facilities that shared staff with
mark haven hadn't received
any directive on this and other homes
will not turn them away
unless they receive this direction from
you
the very next day mark haven got word
its first staff member had tested
positive
and had been working at another home in
british columbia chief public health
officer dr bonnie henry issued an
order banning long-term care workers
from working at more than one facility
on march 26th healthcare workers are
able to work at one facility only
but it was nearly three weeks before
ontario's minister of long-term care
did the same asked why the delay the
minister and the province's top doctor
pointed the finger at each other we rely
on the
advice and recommendations and
directives of the chief medical officer
of health i was not privy
to how all the mechanics of that that
was between the minister of long-term
care
as well as with the minister labor and
with the cabinet to deal with those
issues
as it is an emergency order time after
time
documents reveal frustration and lack of
cooperation between mark haven and
health authorities
on march 29th york region public health
asked mark haven for a list of personnel
who had gone
in and out of the home for contact
racing it was the third such request
the first was more than a week earlier
but according to notes taken by a public
health officer
director of care kevin mckay said it
would take him
a few days because there was only him
alone
no office admin staff more than
2 000 ontarians have died in long-term
care
that's over 10 times more than in
british columbia
we wanted to ask york region public
health and minister fullerton why
but both declined our request for an
interview i think that the
picture that the documents paint really
is a
system which was totally unprepared for
the pandemics and it just seemed that
nobody
you know knew what they were doing jane
meadows is a lawyer and long time
seniors advocate
it was very clear very early on and it's
obvious in the documents that
the homes were not properly trained
didn't have the right kind of
infection control protocols that they
should have had in place
whatever protocols were in place at mark
haven were clearly failing
by 7 15 on the night of march 29th
director of care kevin mckay
called to inform public health that the
first resident
had died 68 year old linda jean
duncan a mother and grandmother of three
children
just one hour later and mckay was on the
phone again
telling public health another resident
was dead
and requesting more death certificates
and did you find out about the other
patients who had passed away
like if any of you were there any of
your
people your residents that you saw
regularly
yes
yes
[Music]
three days later there were more than a
dozen residents and staff infected
and maggie gittins was in the hospital
after caring for the first resident
infected
she had the virus too and all of a
sudden
she was in trouble you thought you were
gonna die
yeah i thought i was gonna die i was
coughing
so bad that i couldn't talk
what happened to you in the hospital
i don't know she really doesn't i don't
know
i know i went to the hospital she didn't
know what happened next because almost
immediately
she was in intensive care unconscious oh
my god it was nerve-racking it was
every day like we didn't sleep at night
it was hard you know it's scary it's
terrifying you don't it's a new virus we
don't know so
my mom's 60 years old she has diabetes
she has high blood pressure
she has high cholesterol heart problems
hi grandma
as time passed hospital staff set up
video calls so her family could talk to
maggie
they were praying for any sign of life
pull through you can do it
it was hard seeing my mom like in a
coma basically she was in a medically
induced coma she was on the ventilator
for 17 days
and then by day i believe it was day 18.
i got a facetime and when i answered
it was my mom and she was off the
ventilator
and like we just burst into tears
couldn't believe it it was like
the best day of my life and we were so
happy as happy as that moment was
more than six months later maggie is
still feeling the effects it's scary for
me
you know to go outside to go
anywhere to go in the store to go
somewhere
where you have people it's the hardest
thing to do now especially
with the second wave
and people is not taking it seriously
while maggie was in hospital fighting
for her life chloe of tivolos was in
mourning after the virus took
her mother's life what do you remember
about the day that your mom
got the virus that you were informed
that your mom and the next phone call
was
i'm sorry i'm telling you that she has
got the virus she has proved
positive three days later she was gone
that was it
that that broke my heart because i
always knew i'd be with my mother at the
end
i mean that's what we do and i couldn't
be there for my mother
you have no idea the guilt that i have
for that
[Applause]
you know it wasn't your fault i know i
know that's what they tell me but
it's hard it's hard it'll take time
in a little more than two months
seventeen of mark haven's 96 residents
were dead
the question remains why did so many
ontario seniors die
in long-term care we have to do
a better job and
at the end of the day the buck stops
with me ontario's government didn't
act to support long-term care homes
desperate for staffing reinforcements
until april 22nd more than a month after
the first confirmed case at markhaven
today we'll be making a formal request
to bring in those extra reinforcements
this
includes resources from public health
agency of canada
and canadian forces personnel ontario
requested soldiers to help stabilize the
province's five hardest hit homes
mark haven didn't make that list and
meanwhile
the political finger-pointing continued
we have been taking
the advice of the best experts our
medical and scientific
experts on this i give them the best
advice i can and but we need the power
and authority of the minister
as well as the ministry and the premier
to back up those with resources and
materials
so we can get on and get the task done
markhaven's outbreak was finally
declared over on may 16
but trust had been shattered we're so
mad at mark haven my brother my sisters
and i were just
so upset with the way things played out
and
the reason why my mom is the way that
she is now it's just
it's so upsetting markhaven is one of
many long-term care homes named in class
action lawsuits we requested an
on-camera interview with the executive
director but he declined on the advice
of lawyers
in an email mike bakewell claimed they
strictly followed public health
guidelines
and praised the efforts of their staff
during the outbreak
many of those employees were traumatized
and won't be going back to work
maggie gittins may never fully recover
but she knows better than most how
vulnerable long-term care residents and
staff
are she just has one simple request
treat us like a human being
you know we are the one who is here
taking care of your loved ones treat us
with respect
coming up on the new reality when
it was becoming clear that 80 of
canadians who died in this pandemic were
living in our long-term care homes we
had
all of our provincial and and federal
leaders coming
out saying the system is broken but
fixing it means
billions of dollars of investment
[Music]
welcome back you'd think we would have
learned more by now
yet at some long-term care facilities
across canada there is an alarming rise
in covid19 cases
and deaths it feels like patterns we saw
in the spring are repeating
now what needs to happen to stop this
catastrophic trend
dr samir sinha is one of the leading
authorities on caring for the elderly
he is the director of geriatrics at
sinai health in toronto
we're now in a second wave across canada
there's out-of-control community spread
happening in places like toronto and
manitoba
are care homes better prepared for this
second wave
we haven't seen the same degree of
outbreaks and i think that reflects the
fact that
homes now have access to ppe they now
have staff that are not working between
multiple settings
for example but what really is
concerning is that we're still seeing
that with a lack of staffing and with
with
other issues in terms of the levels of
community spread that these homes
continue to remain vulnerable
and we are certainly seeing a number of
homes across the country that are having
spectacular outbreaks that were
representing that within many homes
there are weaknesses that still exist
that we have been able to rectify
between the first and second waves
is it that the underlying issue in
society and the health care system
doesn't value residents in long-term
care because they are seen as being
close to death well i think this is a
huge issue because when you actually say
well why did long-term care
homes in canada why were they so
devastated compared to other countries
well the fact is when we compare
ourselves to other rich industrialized
countries
canada spends about a third less on its
long-term care systems
than other countries do so because we
spend a lot less
right off the bat it means that we have
less staffing
available in our homes to deliver the
care that's actually needed
and we also have poor quality facilities
both of these were major factors
that set our homes up to fail i think
the other thing that concerns me is that
we have manitoba for example that's
currently going through its first wave
if you will
and they actually had the opportunity to
witness what happened in the rest of
canada
but what really pains me is actually to
see that
you know they're saying well hindsight's
20 20 and we didn't realize we could get
this bad or these outbreaks could occur
in such a significant way and it's
almost like they didn't actually
really learn the lessons that the rest
of us learned the hard way back in the
spring there was a long delay i think
about three weeks between when bc
ordered personal support workers must
only work in one home
and when that same order was given in
ontario it seemed so basic in hindsight
why do you think it didn't happen right
across the country right away
what we do know is that in a fast-moving
pandemic
you know speed actually matters and
making decisions
in a timely way will actually save lives
so i don't know what the disconnect is
and why so much delays have actually
taken place
in implementing clear science based
evidence but what we do know is that the
provinces that continue to delay
implementing the right
policies and recommendations are seeing
way more deaths that are absolutely
preventable
ontario premier doug ford has said he is
genuinely heartbroken biola deaths in
long-term care and
we know his own mother-in-law lives in a
care home and she caught covid19
it's not that governments and
politicians don't get it so
why has the system failed people so
badly
you know the challenge was that when it
was becoming clear that 80 percent of
canadians who died in this pandemic were
living in our long-term care homes we
had all of our
provincial and and federal leaders
coming out saying the system is broken
we're going to fix it and we'll do what
it takes but fixing it means
billions of dollars of investment
because right now in ontario
we're providing the average resident
with about 2.7 hours of care every day
when our own government's expert
advisors say it should be four hours
so this is where we then need to put an
investment in but governments have been
dragging their feet
and we just saw that in the recent
ontario budget right before the budget
announcement they made a deliberate
point
to actually say we are going to meet
that standard of four hours of care a
day
which would come with a 1.6 billion
dollar price tag
but they said it would come by 2024.25
and then i think what really upset
families and and many advocates like
myself
was to see that in the budget that came
out a few days later
there was no money to be seen even
though the premier reiterated
that we are committed and that we will
find the money when it's necessary
well it's necessary now
[Music]
next week on the new reality we've
never ever planned in halton here to
have a cn
intermodal uh facility in this community
with trucks like in terms like the
exhaust streams they're gonna be
bringing like
all like the carcinogens and things like
that they're probably gonna be bringing
in and i don't want to be breathing that
in i don't want my kids breathing it in
you can't have you know kids on their
tricycles on their bikes
families driving with 15 1600 trucks on
the road this can happen anywhere across
canada and it shouldn't be allowed it's
it's not right
it's the wrong terminal in the wrong
place
at the wrong time and i just feel that
cn is part of the expression
railroading this one through
[Music]
all that and more next saturday on the
new reality
i'm donna friesen thanks for watching
you